et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc Sébastien Chenu Bonjour bonjour
avec nos députés du n'importe
quand
[Musique]
on
est en
arrêt
depuis le début
par exemple
des classeurs bien avant qui se fait
très très peu en réalité est la capacité
déménagement de ventilation des salles
dans les écoles par tout en France on
laisse beaucoup les collectivités seul
se débrouiller et finalement on est
toujours au point de départ et puis
surtout au bout de la chaîne on a les
problématiques de l'hôpital public qui
est toujours la même pas dire que c'est
pandémie elle a pas de problème à tique
évidemment le virus en tant que tel qui
se répand et on essaie de les stopper et
je vous ai donné quelques exemples de
proposition du gouvernement pourrais
prendre à son compte et puis de l'autre
côté quand les gens sont touchés et qui
sont hospitalisés pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux et bien on a un hôpital
public qui n'est pas en capacité
forcément de répondre à la demande parce
que il y a eu 5700 lits fermé depuis le
début de cette pandémie parce que le
Ségur n'a pas servi il faut bien le dire
à grand-chose et donc on se retrouve
toujours au point de départ dans cette
pandémie or moi je veux bien qu'il y ait
une troisième dose on en connaît pas
aujourd'hui il est resté après une
quatrième une 5e
alisation immédiate de sa troisième non
moi je suis pour la liberté la liberté
vaccinale la liberté de prescription
chez le médecin
bien sûr quand on veut avoir accès à
cette troisième dos il faut pouvoir le
faire mais je viens de passer par
exemple sur plus rien on voit les gens
Castex Jean Castex et vacciné pourtant
il a donc été contaminé par le virus
alors ça le protège et tant mieux d'un
cas grave mais ça montre que le 25
la réponse à tout absolument à tout ça
tant mieux tant mieux mais avant son sur
le traitement là encore on a demandé et
vous savez moi je suis nordiste et on a
vu l'Institut Pasteur pleurer réclamer
un soutien beaucoup plus massif pour
travailler sur les retraites le vide
sanitaire ne sert plus à rien on doit
bien
se poser
le sanitaire ne sert à rien
on en a besoin
propriétaire de restaurant et bar de
préfère le passé mais ce choix ça ne
peut pas être celui si ça ne peut pas
être on ferme tous vous avez de passe
Lanester le choix qu'on doit voir c'est
un ciblage des publics sociale
âge d'abord par catégorie de te dire que
par exemple
non je savais pas ça les mesures de
protection par exemple je crois qu'il y
a 11 % des plus de 65 ans je veux pas
dire de bêtises mais qui ne sont pas du
tout vacciner ni par une première n'est
pas une seconde dose pourquoi comment
sont-ils trompe éloigné des centres de
vaccination quel est le rapport à la
vaccination
d'accord mais on a encore beaucoup de
gens qui sont éloignés des hôpitaux
éloigner des centres de vaccination
éloigné de l'information et il y a un
travail de ciblage et aussi après de
ciblage territorial il y a des bassins
où il y a eu des clusters des endroits
où il y a des avantages de gens qui ont
été contaminé et bien la travaillons et
mettez en place les dispositifs de
l'autre côté il y a des régions dans
lesquelles ça se passe pas trop mal non
plus et on va on va pas revenir en
Absurdie c'est
difficilement Nord les contaminations
son temps c'est difficile mais on va pas
revenir sur l'idée demander un pas sa
litière pour monter sur un téléphérique
j'ai pas que ça à la vaccination c'est
pas comme ça que ça s'exprime
c'est-à-dire que vous avez des gens ils
vous avez des centres de vaccination qui
sont fermés ou qui fonctionne beaucoup
moins vous avez une difficulté avec les
tests par exemple tu étais rendu payant
les gens ont beaucoup plus de
difficultés évidemment elle est sur
Facebook et est en réalité on est
aujourd'hui se faire tester que
lorsqu'on a des symptômes
qui sont en plus grand nombre évidemment
je
crois qu'il faut utiliser la batterie
est
possible et à toutes les sensibilités et
aussi
grand nombre de test qui soit positif
puisque pour se tourner vers le test
l'Espagne l'Espagne n'a pas un taux de
contamination qui explose et l'Espagne a
pas de Bastani terre par exemple donc
oui
donc je pense qu'il faut faire confiance
il faut mettre en place des dispositifs
de santé publique
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui
imagine limiter le nombre de
rassemblement où l'empereur des
rassemblements
politique est-ce que c'est une bonne
idée mais je crois que ça a le
gouvernement a d'autres idées
malheureusement je crois que il utilise
beaucoup le covit guide pour essayer de
limiter l'expression des Français alors
à travers les réunions publiques
peut-être demain à travers d'autres
types de réunion des manifestations et
cetera alors qu'en réalité les à partir
du moment que
je pense que il a peur de français je
pense que le gouvernement âge il a peur
des Français et on a bien compris
Emmanuel Macron la bien compris que
quand on parle des covid on ne parle
plus d'autres choses on a vu au moment
des élections régionales quand on parle
du coup vidéos en français et il peur
soyez craintif et bien il y a plus de
place pour un autre débat moi je veux
pas qu'on revienne dans ce type de
moment de la démocratie dans lequel on
cadenassé les Français en leur disant
vous pouvez venir il y a plus de raison
de parler d'autre chose
de limiter la parole des oppositions
on va parler de se passe du côté de la
Guadeloupe de la Martinique ou des
manifestations parfois violente sont en
cours elle s'est tandel dégénère
des pompiers des policiers ont été
touché par la maison.
À tout à l'heure de choses
toutes les violences en Guadeloupe
d'abord en Martinique aujourd'hui elles
ne sont évidemment pas admissible il
faut rétablir l'ordre républicain et on
se poser la question de savoir pourquoi
on en est dans ses explosion de violence
dans ses en Guadeloupe et Martinique
pourquoi on en est là et comment on
résout les problèmes parce que les
résoudre en surface
amènera ce problème revienne la
Guadeloupe et la Martinique est plus
globalement beaucoup de nos département
ou territoire d'outre-mer ou
collectivités d'outre-mer ont été
abandonné ce sont des départements
français comment est-ce qu'on peut
accepter lorsqu'on est le président de
la République que des départs dans un
département français
on ne puisse pas avoir accès à l'eau
potable un tiers des habitants de
Guadeloupe et je pense que ça c'est la
réalité c'est comme un coup de poing
dans la figure et je pense que beaucoup
de mon compatriote
métropole mais aussi découvre se fait un
tiers des habitants de Guadeloupe ont
pas accès à l'eau potable le problème
se déclenche
le révélateur de beaucoup de mal de
notre société
de la crise de l'hôpital public elle a
été de la situation
[Musique]
depuis des années le problème
le problème
c'est une discrimination finalement
accepté tout simplement
beaucoup plus rapidement
vous êtes en métropole aujourd'hui pour
apaiser les choses là-bas il faudrait
dispenser les soignants notamment
d'obligation avec final je le répète moi
je suis favorable à eau libre choix
concernant le isation vaccinal
je pense que chacun doit mesurer
série ce que son bene ses bénéfices avec
ceux-ci le fait d'avoir mis à la porte
un syndrome de soignant a été un
déclencheur en Guadeloupe peut-être
aussi en Martinique d'après ce que je
peux comprendre et on est dans des
territoires il faut bien dire il y a un
sentiment très fort
et
et aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il faut y aller plus vite possible ça
fait bien longtemps qu'il aurait dû le
faire bien sûr qu'il doit prendre ses
sujets à bras-le-corps Emmanuel Macron
découvre un centre de problème à Saint
Croix des élections le pouvoir d'achat
la sécurité pas seulement Guadeloupe la
sécurité de nos compatriotes et
problèmes migratoires
la vie quotidienne ne l'intéresse pas le
problème c'est que Macron a été
aucunement intéressé par la vie
quotidienne des Français et aujourd'hui
tout ça ressurgit parce que elle
c'est une bonne chose selon vous
celui qui a abandonné
le gouvernement et pas de problème
moi
évidemment mais de Boulogne
nos pêcheurs ont été finalement laissé à
l'abandon on leur dit tout simplement
prenez un chèque et puis laisser vos
bateau
non mais c'est la réalité c'est que ce
gouvernement plie les Gaules texto
gouvernement parce qu'il est soumis à
l'Union européenne accepte pas
d'enclencher un bras de fer avec l'Union
européenne Emmanuel Macron viens
constater il
a
laissé à l'abandon
ils ont une chose sympa ils défendent
leurs intérêts le problème c'est que je
ne descends pas l'intérêt de la France
il défend les intérêts de l'Union
européenne il ne défend pas les intérêts
des Français les Britanniques défendent
leurs intérêts beaucoup finalement de
dirigeants la sur la planète quelles que
soient les options politiques défend les
intérieurs pays de Macron défend les
intérêts de tu sors de la France c'est
quand même problématique la France il
faudrait faire comme la vendre comme les
l'Angleterre finalement non pour
défendre les intérêts de la France il
faut se dire qu'on peut avoir des
relations bilatérales qu'il soit
davantage équilibré et il faut en avoir
la volonté je pense qu'il est ce
président qui aurait pu être présent de
n'importe quel pays il est ce président
totalement
il est le président qui n'a pas de
relation charnelle avec les Français le
président qui est
très mal il a très mal il n'est pas
illégitime ce n'est pas ce que je suis
en train de Dieu n'est pas illégitime
mais je dis que c'est le président n'a
pas de relation charnelle avec les
Français et en fait c'est ça devient ça
a été très problématique de retouche
mandat on l'a vu avec les gilet jaune
moi j'ai toujours une pensée pour les
chez les jeunes parce que quand je vois
le prix des carburants aujourd'hui je me
dis que nos amis gilet jaune sur les
ronds-points qui ont été des lanceurs
d'alerte et bien
mais le problème de ce gouvernement
c'est qui là et on l'a vu sur le pouvoir
d'achat il a fait uniquement du
colmatage il y a pas de souci on nous
avait dit manuel Macron à l'économie
extraordinaire ici même le Sénat a
racheté la partie recette du budget
parce qu'en fait ça part dans tous les
sens on nous avait dit vous verrez
Emmanuel Macron à l'international ça va
être quelque chose merci on a vu on se
fait humilier avec l'Australie et les
États-Unis on nous a dit mais Emmanuel
Macron c'est un type qui va réconcilier
les Français c'est on a vu il a divisé
les Français comme jamais il va falloir
réparer tout ça et Marine Le Pen
aujourd'hui qui peut réparer tout ça
est
républicain emmener
pour dans le cas de ce que vous voulez
suivez c'est non je vais regarder ok
désolé mais le problème est républicain
c'est
incroyable à 20h01 le soir du premier
tour monsieur Barnier madame Pécresse
Monsieur Bertrand soutenu désormais par
Monsieur Muselier et ses amis en marche
appelleront à Emmanuel Macron
le soir du premier tour la bouche en
cœur nous appelons a voté Emmanuel
Macron mais ils ont déjà
parce que en fait il ne représente pas
ce que je dis représente pas une
alternative à la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron ce qu'il propose et
parler d'une voix et
problème
problème des petites retraites exetera
et bien aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
l'ensemble de la classe politique fait
le même constat que nous le constat et
maintenant il pleut je suis dans un
programme pour les solutions parce que
évidemment après avoir été dans le déni
pendant des années différence entre une
pioche sur la sécurité programme
évidemment parce qu'ils ont compris que
c'était la solution mais le problème
c'est qu'ils ont la main
fondamentalement deux courage non alors
on leur tend la main on a dit de Zemmour
à Montebourg à tout le monde a des gens
secteur de rassembler les Français faire
l'aire de Manuel Macron sur un certain
nombre de proposition qui sont bien
connus qui sont notamment celle dont je
viens de vous parler et bien ça
nécessite elle vient de se tourner vers
tout le monde mais les appareils
politique les républicains
thématiquement parce que Arnaud
Montebourg un discours sur le
libéralisme sur la mondialisation qui
est intéressant et il ne lui disant ce
discours il est tout à fait compatible
avec ce que nous pensons donc venez
plutôt nous donner un coup de main
[Musique]
libéralisme sur le mondialisme sur la
place de la souveraineté la France bien
sûr sur le plan économique oui bien sûr
Marine Le Pen
service national
qu'il vous prenez un certain nombre de
la raison de dire ça en fait Éric
Zemmour dans un premier temps un peu
voilà le présenter comme quelqu'un de
nouveau
et bien attirer le regard et
probablement dans les intentions de vote
des gens se disent ah bah tiens c'est la
nouveauté ça peut nous intéresser il
comprit venant du rassemblement national
et des républicains et puis dans un
second temps on a vu l'homme à la
manœuvre on a vu le polémiste on a vu
l'homme qui disait il faut changer les
prénoms des jeunes gens dans notre pays
et ça va résoudre le problème c'était
pas crédible on a vu l'homme des
polémiques on a vu un discours très dur
très gentil social est à côté chez Éric
Zemmour et quand même dit c'est un de
vos confrères contre lui parlent du
travail des difficultés d'arriver en
retraite cassée par le travail qui
répond le travail c'est la santé donc on
va juste un homme qui avait beaucoup de
légèreté et beaucoup de désinvolture
finalement n'a aucune solution pour les
pour résoudre les problèmes des Français
n'est pas rentré ce que disait Marion
maréchal très bien d'ailleurs n'est pas
rentré dans la vie présidentielle et
personne aujourd'hui ne le générique
c'est bon évidemment président de la
République ça marche pas
mais ça montre que ça ne s'improvise pas
de vouloir dirigé la France ça ne
s'improvise pas Éric Zemmour et un
polémiste il sait sur un plateau être
très à l'aise et puis c'est interview
catastrophique sur France Info
avant-hier 0 solution 0 idée de problème
nous donner un coup de main pour
Marine Le Pen
méprisant alors peut-être parce que
Marine Le Pen est une femme et qu'on
sait qu'il porte un regard sur les
femmes et le pouvoir qui est quand même
un regard très pardon
en tous les cas il y a il y a ce côté
moi je ne me l'explique pas autrement
Éric Zemmour porte à regard sur une
femme les femmes et le pouvoir que tu as
rien dans quel il dit là où les femmes
arrive le pouvoir c'est la porte donc
vivement ça doit lui donner quelques
vapeur lorsqu'il voit Marine Le Pen
du premier tour il
y a pas de problème
donc
on a besoin de tout le monde donc ça
sert à rien
[Musique]
personne interrogée juste que Marine Le
Pen est d'extrême droite c'est l'échec
total de la diabolisation donc dans ce
sondage odoxa il y a beaucoup de points
de très d'images comment on dit qu'ils
sont bien meilleur que ce site moi je
crois que Marine Le Pen et évidemment
pas dès que j'ai le droit d'avoir parce
que parce que je pense que d'abord la
gauche et la droite tel qu'on perçoit
aujourd'hui ça ne veut plus rien dire
tout à l'heure je vous parler d'Arnaud
Montebourg mais tout comme je suis
capable de te parler d'Éric Zemmour pour
les gens qui viennent d'horizons
différentes la gauche et la droite et
pourtant ils sont je crois capable de se
retrouver sur un programme sur
l'indépendance à souveraineté la France
l'autorité de l'État à l'État stratège
exetera donc je
crois que voilà
mais je pense que c'est
montrer à travers ce qu'elle est comme
femme comme responsable politique à
travers ces propositions qu'elle était
une authentique républicaine capable de
rassembler les Français et surtout elle
en a la volonté je suis pas sûr que ce
soit la volonté de tous ses concurrents
et adversaire au premier rang desquels
Emmanuel Macron que de rassembler les
Français justement j'ai lu attentivement
les propositions qu'elle a pu faire ces
derniers jours et je voulais vous
expliquer certaines elle a promis
notamment si elle était élu d'exonérer
d'impôt les revenus de tous les jeunes
jusqu'à 30 ans et je voulais savoir
est-ce que c'est inclus les plus riches
quand on sait que selon une étude de
2019 certains commence à plus de 3004
1000 € par mois est-ce que vous parliez
de proposition de d'Éric Zemmour qui
exclut et les plus pauvres est-ce que
c'est égalitaire la logique de sa
proposition d'abord pourquoi vouloir
exonéré d'impôt sur le revenu les moins
de 30 ans d'abord pour pas qu'il s'en
aille on a une déperdition d'énergie de
talent de jeunes gens de jeunes Français
qui veulent partir à l'étranger
livre exercer leur métier fonder leur
famille et ensuite
surtout pas mais les plus diplômés et
ensuite il ne revienne pas et c'est tout
un pays qui laisse partir des
générations entière de jeunes gens qui
ont du talent ce n'est pas un pays qui a
beaucoup d'avenir donc il faut essayer
de retenir donc ces propositions elle
est bien sûr il y a des cas très
particulier qui gagne beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent bien sûr ça existe c'est très
marginal aussi
nous partons sur les dispositifs qui
s'adresse à tout le monde qui pourrait
avoir techniquement des effets correctif
sur Envoyer qu'il y avait des billets ou
des angles morts évidemment il faut pas
être une logique à cette proposition il
peut y avoir des effets correctif
nécessaire mais elle s'adresse en grande
majorité à tous ces jeunes sont veux
retenir et à qui on veut donner un coup
de pouce main des jeunes qui arrive sur
le marché du travail quand vous payez
2000 € vous payez déjà des impôts
exonéré de cotisations patronales cette
fois-ci les entreprises qui augmente de
10 % les salaires de ce qui gagne
jusqu'à 3 fois le SMIC là aussi est une
volonté l'égalitarisme trois fois le
SMIC c'est plus 3000 € net jusqu'à 3
pour le signe ça veut dire que à partir
du SMIC des données du pouvoir d'achat
au français c'est
autre chose que ce que ce dont nous
avons hérité à travers notre histoire
notre culture et puis rendre en France
et leur argent tu sais que nous ne
voulons pas que les efforts des Français
avec qui ont contribué à ériger un
système social qui permet à chacun
d'être protégé dans notre pays que les
efforts des Français bénéfice y a
d'autres c'est aussi toute cette
problématique de la préférence la
priorité nationale que nous mettons sur
le tapis et c'est aussi redonner du
pouvoir d'achat on le fait oui oui elle
était chiffres et elle est tout à fait
elle est tout à fait possible avant
parce qu'on va faire nationale
on a la priorité nationale on peut aller
dans cette on peut passer cette mesure
[Musique]